sa convenance ou popularité parce qu'on
a vu au début c'est forcément un
concours de popularité pour l'insant
gourmet prime on se fout un peu de ce
qui va se passer sur l'a7 à part ce
qu'il faut garder donc un coup et on en
parle attaque mais aussi bien ceux qui
n'ont pas moi mais vous plaît ça vous
fait vous êtes mazurie bout et il
s'appellerait s'il vous plaît donc moi
je pense que pendant sa dette pendant
pendant cinq six semaines il faut
équilibrer le show après envoi l'appui
des comptes après excuse moi mais en
panne on finit à non mais après tu as
les vingt dix il va rester les meilleurs
danseurs et vers la fin on va évidemment
où les meilleurs de danse mais pour le
pour l'instant c'est un choix gagnant la
plupart des lions sont pas connues alors
les séries du les twittos souhaitait
très agacé je vous le dis cette semaine
surtout pas par patrick dupont voilà qui
disait et il les a indignés parce qu'il
dit qu'ils le trouvent trop sympa et que
certains candidats aux sévères avec
d'eau notamment sa note attribuée à
vincent moscato après sa note juger mais
drg médiocre par l'amazoo majorité des
téléspectateurs
alors il faut savoir cette année est qu
à la grande surprise générale ce sont
les trois derniers du classement qui ont
été sauvés par le public et donc vous
avez une compil basile boli jean-phi
janssen et moscato
mais c'est vrai qu'ils font le spectacle
et ils sont plus populaires maintenir
après bien sûr sur l'élimination danois
et on je voudrais dire il ya été somme
toute logique il ya six marquez qui est
pas content après gilbert d'élaborer de
m'envoyer un sms regarde
[Musique]
c'est mon île
transforme
quai de gare
tu t'en vas
suis malade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors est donc content dans ce concours
de popularité regarder pour les gens
voient leur état 82% donc ça sa pièce
vraiment voilà ce qui se passe dans
l'émission alors les imitent les
éliminations sont elles joué d'avancé la
grande question qu'on vous pose
dites nous ce que vous en pensez parce
que c'est vrai ce prime a donc été
marquée par une double élimination
la vôtre anwar est celle de carla ginola
jugée injuste par les téléspectateurs ça
a été un déferlement de tweet alors on
va regarder votre prestation à noir et
malgré vos deux prestations saluées par
le jury et le public c'est vous et carla
qui vous fait éliminer c'était très
émouvant allemande dans le tuer mais je
vous dis qu'on va d'abord revoir mais
pas de prestations aprilia
[Musique]
on va y arriver l'ixus 130 points
alward on a été très bien notée par les
membres du jury l'actrice marqué 5 hymne
écrit beaucoup de sms je voulais donner
à noir donc et c'est vrai que tu t'es
fait éliminer avec carla ginola c'était
très émouvant va voir votre élimination
même le riz est donc extrêmement surpris
à thoune avait semblé alors les
téléspectateurs ont trouvé ça injuste
arrêtez s'il vous plais c'est tous les
ans pareil à quand la fin de ces votes
du public qui note à la notoriété et non
les capacités faudrait que le public
arrête de voter c'est du grand n'importe
quoi comment les notes ont basculé et
anouar vous est-ce que vous avez été
déçu ce que vous attendiez à votre
élimination
non franchement non et tout le monde me
disais que j'allais un peu faire un beau
parcours dans ses missions mais même les
danseurs possibilité j'allais faire un
beau parcours dans la vie regardez
après non moi je pense pas que en fait
je pense qu'il ya deux publics bien il
ya le public général il ya et dans le
public général vient tout type il ya une
petite partie du public qui botte
d'ailleurs c'est une toute petite partie
après je public là et votent pour qu'il
veut on sait pas trop comment les gens
qui connaît le plus
pas forcément non parce que les
dernières éditions il ya eu rails elle
même c'est inouï
non faut arrêter avec ça c'est vous avez
été éliminés après après mois après mois
sera qu on dit souvent c'est que souvent
le public un réflexe est de voter
beaucoup pour les gens qui sont mal
notés qui sont mal embarqués et ils ont
le réflexe de les sauver et que tu
attends je vais juste de dire un truc
c'est dans ces cas là si c'était le pub
populaire qui était enfin qu'ils
allaient avoir le plus de votes aux
photos extraits première parce que la
star absolue est la star de démission
elle rend d'entre eux qui a une ovation
elle est mais en plus elle danse
franchement démographique elle est
incroyable et c'est mérité et
franchement non donc elle serait pas
dans les barrages
alors je vous dire alors vous avez été
éliminés c'est un grand moment d'émotion
vous a senti très très très ému lors de
votre élimination car avec cette
émission c'était votre rêve même un peu
ouais c'est péché qui fait franchement
j'ai kiffé c'est une super émission
franchement on dit beaucoup de choses
sur cette émission
et pas forcément vrai parce que il ya
des gens incroyables je vous assure
série on va on va revenir justement sur
les votes parce que les votes on peut
les manipuler comme on veut on va vous
expliquer tout ça dans un instant
voulons regarder la manière
l'élimination danois bravo terrance tels
efforts auto
mon public vous a soutenu vous continuer
la compétition et vous serez là la
semaine prochaine de retour sur cet
article alors il ya même franck
gastambide votre votre ami de mon ami
voilà francs 4 buts est fière de toi mon
petit frère anouar toubali qu'elle
sketch cette émission hashtag d'alstom
sensiblement et d'aimer un arrêt fronde
du coup franc qui reste énervé tout le
week-end devant sa télé l'analyse sur
plein de programmes correct et sur le
téléshopping écrite et les chauffeurs
-30% sur le couple minceur alors qu'en
fait ces trucs pour ça on était très en
forme il a fait aussi un 28 sûr c'est
que la télé valérie benaïm marre de voir
mon ex à la théorie reversés à cette
date-là la présentation hashtag mon ex
ce poulet est énorme il était déchaîné
il a même plutôt sur motus comme par
hasard dans motus nathalie tire deux
fois de suite la boule noire bande de
tricheurs faire le tour et juste voir
les clés chéri est ce que vous allez
nous expliquer comment on peut donc
influencer le vote
et ça écoutez bien parce que mine de
rien on fait ce qu'on veut dans une
émission de vote benjamin castaldi vous
en avez fait souvent et vous savez
comment ça se passe quand la vérité
alors dans les districts dans les
émissions que moi j'ai déjà benjamin
castaldi est avérée non c'est ce que me
disent les avais déjà déjà en termes de
production
il ya une méthode très simple c'est que
j'aime c'est le premier temps on se
promet dont on parle qui a plus de temps
de voter
déjà ça c'est la main après deux lancers
fois parce qu il faudrait c'est ouvert à
tous c'est ouvert les votes non les
votes ils sont ouverts à la fin qu'on
les valeurs tout mais en fonction de
leurs sabots après on peut évidemment
passer des messages subliminaux je les
fais moi dans deux éditions dont bien
sûr quand il y avait deux candidats et
ont bien qu'on préfère à l'autre on peut
dire ah je vous annonce que intel et
plus et semblerait en danger ça c'est
facile
et après dans le cadre de dans ce
message il a enquêté c'est ce week end
c'est vrai que la notation la double
notation entre le jury et ce que je
fusse que puisque buck le public
évidemment commenteront modifie les
points avec un classement de 11 à 1 que
le premier en soins l'année à un point
évidemment la production je pense je
suis pas dedans mais je pense que ils
ont les informations sur le voting est
forcément est forcément à mon avis j'ai
des rentes yeux des consignes données
que je dis que je devrais pas dire est
que j'ai eu des échos
202 de la prod la froide je vais dire un
truc ils sont et je pas le droit de le
dire mais ouais non mais ils sont déçus
que je parte ils sont déçus que je pars
et je suis des points a battu c'est
pourquoi le préfet ouais c'est pour me
dire tu assuré qu'en fait je pense que
justement ce système là les à leur a
échappé c'est qu'ils pensent qu'ils
avaient conduit à l'accident
non il y avait une tête et qui a été
passée on leur a dit voilà pour que ça
passe mieux il faut faire comme ça et la
vérité c'est que ça n'est pas passé
parce que pour le coup ils sont fait
avoir à propre jeu allégée est-ce qu'on
peut influencer les votes les
obligations sont celles jouées d'avancé
dit nous oui ou non
et là gilles j'aimerais que vous nous
expliquer alors donc en fait il ya deux
votes qui comptent chacun pour 50 %
d'accord il ya le vote du jury
par exemple là vous avez liot qui était
première avec 67 points s'est converti
en points est là on ce point mais jansen
ce qui était le dernier il a un point ça
c'est le vote du jury et le public votée
on additionne les points
si vous êtes premier au jury premier au
public vous avez donc 22 points d'accord
donc à ce moment là le public
ils ne peuvent pas trop savoir ils ont
fait des études de popularité hills avec
carla ginola était pas populaire
et je peux vous révéler qu'elle a été
dernière au vote du public elle a eu un
point
elle avait pourtant elle était pourtant
5e avec 7 points au vote du jury mais ça
n'a pas suffi à les décoller mais
voulait pas ils voulaient qu'elle parte
il savait il avait étudié et comme je
voulais dit ils vous ont sacrifié à noir
mais c'est ça qui est dégueulasse moi je
vous le dis mais je vais vous sinon ils
peuvent écrire alors qu'il voulait pas
que ce côté face c'est le public qui
vote qu'il est différent encore une fois
du public général c'est le public qui
vote toute petite partie non si vous
voulez pas que vous teniez le shérif ça
la vérité julie la désinfo rappelez-vous
l'an dernier il nous avait dit que ariel
donc arielle dombasle allait sortir
et oui il avait dit elle va sortir à la
prochaine émission et bien regardez ce
qui s'est passé l'an dernier est sorti
regardez dans danse avec les stars
arielle dombasle a signé pour quatre
prime
ouais et après c'est elle qui décidera
si elle part ou si elle rêve alors c'est
sûr donc ceux de l'année prochaine ce
sont pour son dernier voilà ça sera
dernier mais à pas celle qui décide a
commenté je suis sûr de ça d'accord j'ai
bossé tout le week-end
c'est quand même fou qu'arielle dombasle
soit éliminé je vous le dis c'est
incroyable j'ai le gardé à vue 10 et
donc arielle dombasle a été l'idée je
vous le dis on peut influencer les votes
dans une émission de vote 2 2 voilà deux
dans une émission comme ça et d ailleurs
il ya un autre truc c'est que ce qui est
étonnant c'est que tous les candidats ne
dispose pas du même temps de vote
est-ce que ça c'est vrai ou pas non ça
c'est bon c'est vrai faut pas ressasser
tout débute à la fin
les présentations alors quand on peut
influencer
alors je suis la bbc au téléphone donc
les produits valent les producteurs les
ayants droit et ils m'ont dit que la
méthode de vote in est la même dans le
monde entier rappelons que danse avec
les stars est décliné en cinq ans il n'y
a aucune instrumentalisation des jurys à
cela y a pas d'oreillettes contrairement
à ce qu'on peut entendre depuis la
saison il n'y ait rien du temps mais
maxi et angie je donne l'information
officielle de la vie difficile
si l'on donné à patrick dupont c'est
pour ça qu'ils mais des neuf c'est pour
ça qu'ils déclenchent tremblement de
terre patrick dupont si l'erreur de
casting ce domaine il fait n'importe
quoi servait sa place
novelli mais laissez moi laissez moi
finir d'eau qui laminent 9 à pamela
anderson parce que comme je voulais
d'iselle i télé qu'ordinaire il était
daoui les cherry est ce que vous pensez
que les éliminations sont déjà joué là
ce qui nous plaît mais bien sûr il est
dit que la vérité parce que je sais que
vous avez des infos ou si les
téléspectateurs attendent la vérité et
le jardin l'année alors oui j'ai déjà
joué d'avancé pour la fois il a raison
est-ce que c'est déjà joué d'avancé ou
pas en tous les cas ils ont un scénario
écrit d'avancé soit notre âge on
l'abandonné sais pas tu rien sauf que
parfois ça leur échappe
mais dans leur tête ils dévoilent assez
macho et il a raison jean entre un oeuf
qui est une trêve et d'excellentes notes
et un set ça peut tout changer à la fin
oui il ya eu des cas mais oui
les deux écoles n'ont qu'à la fin avec
le mode public de points ça peut
évidemment faire la santé alors ça fait
les frais est ce que c est ce que je
vous le dis la question elle est sympa
ce que les annulations sera jouée
d'avancé
oui moi je pamela anderson sera plus là
après la quatrième émission je réalisais
des savoirs
évidemment tout est joué d'avancé tm
faut pas prendre tes fins pour débite
des débiles ils vont pas éliminer les
jaune et vert
ils font tous regarder leurs stars le
peu de stars ça c'est vrai on fait le
tour de table oui bien sûr le nom et
pourquoi avoir fait gagner loïc noter
qu'il est inconnu du public pour voir
autre chose parce que aux arédiens à ses
débuts au tournant trognon roussillon
c'est que ça reste une notion de danse
les bons quand même les bons les vrais
bons danseurs rêve d'un programme
effectivement dans les bons danseurs
même si on est inconnu on peut gagner
alors voilà j'ai tout écrit d'avancé ce
qui est dégueulasse encore une fois
c'est cannois était la victime le jet de
la machination de la production est sage
leur pardonnerai jamais côté produit
joséphine ange gardien
alors que la belle allée las marième
vanneste remettait d'instrumentalisation
c'est justement qu'un noir s'en va aleri
qu'une collatéral moi j'espère que c'est
pas vrai j'espère qu'ils prennent pas
les gens pour des rebelles à bien
exprimer
gillet d'ig pas malin va sortir donc ca
sort et c'est à dire qu'il aura eu
raison de 2 fois arielle dombasle et
pamela raison chaque année fait ça mais
là j'ai vu pamela lors des entraînements
aléas dont abala va pas sortir alors
série l'a dit qu'elle se retire au bout
de la quatrième sur la teuf lagarde est
possible au quatrième je vous le dis il
a dit et se trompe jamais géraldine moi
je pense pas que ce soit jouée d'avancé
je voudrais demander à gilles qui va
gagner alors puisqu'ils c'est tout voilà
mais sa précieuse je sais pas j'ai pas
libre de scénario je n'ai pas le livre
qui est écrit le livre est écrit je ne
vais pas la meilleure idée mais se
retient pour que ce soit parce qu'on est
l'un des vilains que géraldine il donne
il a donné des infos chaque année mais
aussi gelé critiqué comme vous chaque
année je vous jure que c'est vrai chaque
à l'airé des issarts tiges il dit
n'importe quoi
et chaque année il nous a bluffés parce
que mine de rien il a les infos gilles
verdez et c'est un régionaliste et je
peux vous dire que c'est celui qui bosse
le plus ici pas du tout joli 9 fois sur
10 et combien de fois je suis tombé
dessus neuf fois sur dix il a le bon
scénario et il est quand même très bon
alors là il m'a remis en place plus
d'une fois et avoir conclure il faut
d'abord rappeler que c'est un spectacle
et que forcément il ya bien garder des
jambes comme buscato le plus loin au
détriment d'autres meilleurs danseurs
jeudi jusqu'au moment dès lors on était
parti très vite et c'était lui qui
faisait le chant la saison une étape
arrivant feeder anwar anwar est ce que
tu as le sentiment d'avoir été biaisée
par la production
non au contraire et je vais même vous
dire un truc c'est que moi ils me
mettaient enfin sur les deux prime ils
vont me en quatrième position
ça veut dire un débile et ben dis donc
ça veut dire que il croit en vous voilà
une baisse à marcher 500 places vous
avez passé un moment les abus le
magnifique
dans ce numéro 10 je vous assure et je
dis pas ça pour être fair-play ou pour
faire beau ou qua non j'ai vraiment
passé quatre semaines incroyables une
équipe incroyable des gens formidables
des gens gentils et humainement et voilà
un grand kiff pour moi on va voir ce
qu'on pense et élégant régulateur tiens
voilà était très vite et oui oui nos
poches il vous avez convaincu les
téléspectateurs et jouait dur
je tiens mes petites choses c'est vrai
qu'on va d'un petit peu karine ferri
chaque semaine parce qu'on est à peine
plus de place et que karine
personnellement moi je l'aimais
énormément et karine voilà je sais qu'à
nous regardent souvent j'ai fait un gros
bisou et on aimerait qu'elle prenne
encore plus de place dans vos armes
parce que je pense qu'elles le méritent
et qu'elle a elle a un jeu vous dire la
vérité j'ai même voulu engager sur ces
bidons pour vous dire que je trouve
qu'elle a finalement passé non elle a
préféré faire danse avec les stars mais
j'espère qu'elle va voilà qu'elle
s'éclate dessus